سواء كنت تقضي وقتك على الأريكة
أو مع بعض الكربوهيدرات المريحة ، فإن زيادة الوزن
أثناء الوباء أمر
شائع جدًا في دراسة نُشرت في
المجلة الطبية Jama network
open قام الباحثون بفحص
قياسات الوزن لما يقرب من 270 مشاركًا
من الأول من فبراير إلى الأول من شهر فبراير.
يونيو 2020.
في المتوسط ، اكتسب أولئك الذين تمت دراستهم 1.8 رط
شهريًا أثناء المأوى في مكان ال
لبات في مارس وأبريل إذ
كنت في نفس القارب ، يم
ن أن تساعدك أربعة أشياء بسيطة في إعادتك إلى المسار الصحيح أو
ًا ضخ البروتين وفقًا لخ
ير الصحة واللياقة البدنية ستيفاني  منصور من
خلال تناول المزيد من البروتين ،
ستساعد في استقرار مستويات السكر في الدم ،
الأمر
الذي سيقلل من هذا الرعي الطائش
طوال اليوم
التالي ، وشرب الكثير من الماء ، تقول منصور إن
الكثير من الناس يخطئون في الشعور بالعطش
بسبب الجوع قبل أن تأكل أي شيء
تقوله
تناول كوبًا من الماء ، ثالثًا ، اجعل
الحركة أكثر
متعة ، فقد تجعلك على الأرجح ترغب
في ممارسة
شيء يمكن تحقيقه قد
يستغرق 20 دقيقة
المشي ، يمكن أن تكون اليوجا تمتد على
مكتبك ، قد
يكون من الروتين اليومي في الصباح أن تستيقظ
قلبك
وتطلقك لبدء اليوم أخيرًا
يقول منصور أن تجعل رأسك في
اللعبة
يمنحك بعض النعمة بدلاً من انتقاد
نفسك مهما كان  يمكن أن تقول
لنفسك كل يوم أن تعزيز
علاقة إيجابية مع
نفسك سيجعلك ترغب في اتخاذ
خيارات غذائية صحية
والحصول على تمرين من أجل الصحة الدقيقة التي
أحتاجها.